Alright, Pacific Rim, man. I am pumped to
talk about this movie!
I can tell.
The only problem is... how do we decide who's
gonna do the pros and who's gonna do the cons.
What do you mean?
Well, we're both gonna want to do the pros,
so you know, how do we choose. Do we flip
a coin or what?
I do not mind doing the cons, alright? That
doesn't bother me.
You mother*cker. You didn't like Pacific Rim?!
No, that's not even remotely what I said.
I just saw enough wrong with it that I don't
mind taking the con side in an argument.
You mother*cker.
Whatever. I can't help it.
Okay. Whatever. I'm going first, though.
Do it. You go first.
The robot drags a f*cking cargo ship through
the streets of Hong Kong and beats up a giant
alien monster with it!!
Yeah, that was pretty awesome.
(That was easy)
Okay, my turn, now. That's only awesome at
the expense of story and character.
What?
Like, it's so obvious they spent so much on
the robots they just had an intern who watched
too many Roland Emmerich movies be the screenwriter.
What's there to script? Exterior: Day: Robot
punches monster.
That's about how they approached it, yeah.
I mean, they couldn't have more clichés in
this movie if they tried. Will the two new
partners get along? Will they fall in love?
Will the grizzled old veteran come out of
retirement to save the day? Will the scientist
storyline make me want to choke a b*tch? None
of those questions have good answers.
Man, I liked all that stuff. Are you—do
you mean to tell me that you knew they were
going to fall in love, like, in the beginning
of the movie? Cause I didn't see that coming
at all.
That's only because you were too busy masturbating
to the robot fights.
I did that when I got home, alright? I am
an adult.
Whatever. It's my point. (That was easy)
The robot drags a f*cking cargo ship through
the streets of Hong Kong and beats up a giant
alien monster with it!!
I know, but you already used that.
It's worth more than one point!
No, it's not. Not according to the rules.
(That was easy) I'm sorry. Now, let's talk
about the accents for a second.
Accents?
I'd like to talk about the accents. Specificall
Idris Elba. That guy's a god of accents. I
watched all 5 seasons of The Wire twice before
I even knew he was British. But what the hell
is up with his accent in this movie? It's
like, Scottish at times, and English at times,
and a little Australian, South African. It's
all over the place. It's really distracting.
I didn't notice. I was too busy paying attention
to the bad-ass locker-room speeches.
If you didn't notice the accents, then you
can't argue against that. (That was easy).
That one's mine too.
Alright, my turn. The bad-ass locker room
speeches!
You know, I'm kinda glad you did that, actually.
Because the speeches are, indeed, terrible.
Like, they're cheesy—there's one speech
where it's just him and the other guy talking
in a room, and he starts screaming all of
the sudden like there's a thousand guys needing
to be inspired. It's ridiculous. (That was
easy).
You have to give me a chance to argue back.
Fine, argue back.
Those speeches were inspiring to me. Dude,
what do you want from a giant robot punching
aliens movie, like, Oscar-caliber acting?
I wish you could hear how you sound right
now. You sound exactly like those people who
defend their love of the Transformers movies
by saying basically the same thing. Look,
I don't mind if the movie wants to say, "Hey,
there's a crack in the ocean and aliens can
come through it," and then never address it
again. That's fine with me. I don't care if
they want to say, you know, robot fighting
is more important to us than character development.
That's fine with me. But even the "don't take
me seriously" fun, casual movie can still
be made well. Don't you think?
The robot drags a f*cking cargo ship through
the streets of Hong Kong and beats up a giant
alien monster with it!!
Man, you are the reason they're gonna make
six more of these things over the next ten
years.
That... sounds awesome to me.
Pacific Rim 2: More Rimming
Man, I am all over that sh*t.
Pacific Rim 2: More Inception Sounds.
Okay, that was a little distracting.
BWAAAAAAAAHHHM!
How many people do you think stayed for the
after-credits scene in this movie?
Pacific Rim has an after-credits scene?